امام الامر الواقع واعتباري اثيوبيا
قرارات مجلس الامن غير ملزمه وصلت ازمه
السد الى سد بالاساس مصر والسودان
تواجهتها سابقا الى مجلس الامن وفق البند
السادس صلاحيات المجلس وفق هذا البند هي
تقديم توصيات للاطراف المتنازعه للعوده
الى طاوله الحوار بالنسبه لاثيوبيا السد
اساسي لتنميه اقتصاديه فهي تريد تشغيل 16
توربينا لتوفير الطاقه ل60 من الاثيوبيين
معادله مقلقه بالنسبه لمصر فكميه المياه
التي تصلها ستتناقص ومتابعه ذلك
حصه مصر من النيل تبلغ 55 مليار متر مكعب
سنويا الملء الرابع اذا تم بشكل كامل فهو
يستهدف الوصول بحجم المياه التي سيتم
تخزينها الى 40 مليار متر مكعب لو خسرت
مصر 5 مليارات متر مكعب من المياه مثلا
فسيؤدي ذلك الى خساره مليون فدان من
الثمانيه ملايين اجمالي الاراضي الزراعيه
بحسب دراسه من جامعه كاليفورنيا وهنا
انعكاس كبير للموقف المصري وواقع التهديد
الغذائي التي تنطلق منها الازمه ووفقا
للدراسه نفس الدراسه فانه في اسوا
السيناريوهات السيناريوه السنوات الثلاث
للملء سيفقد ستفقد قرابه اربعه ملايين
و750 الف عامل بالزراعه في مصر مصدر دخلهم
من اصل 5 ملايين ونصف المليون عامل
اما السودان اللاعب الثاني في الازمه وهو
دوله مصب حصته المائيه 18 مليار متر مكعب
من نهر النيل السودان واذا حرمه الملء
الرابع من خمسه مليارات متر مكعب متوقعه
هذا العام فهو على عكس مصر التي تمتلك
السد العالي ما يجعل خساره مصر من المياه
خساره من فائض فان اكبر سدود السودان
الرصيرس لا تتجاوز سعته التخزينيه 10% من
سعه سد النهضه السدود الصغيره تضع السودان
في وضع حرج في اي موسم جفاف سابق الاهم في
هذه المشكله ما سيحدث بعد ذلك